i had this hotel room for a week on the
sixth day
i finished it on the seventh day i
rested
and
on the seventh day i
tried to write a letter to my secretary
to tell her how i wanted this to be
typed up
and i couldn't finish the sentence
uh it was gone the music was gone i
would start writing and all of a sudden
i said now what was i going to say it
it was flowing for six days and then it
stopped and so i think it's an
inspiration that i can't just turn on
and turn off either
well i understand you you've been
considering all kinds of numbers under
the sun and uh probably the greatest
kind of numbers because it includes
every
everything uh
it's the surreal numbers the name
actually uh came to me in the middle of
the night i have no idea
i i have a vague
recollection that i saw at one point a
french paper that talked about no
ordinary
i don't pronounce it well but sort of
ordinal numbers i've never been able to
track down that paper and i don't know
if i heard about it before after i
thought of the name surreal lump but um
you'll see that it's a great name after
you understand what surreal numbers are
and john conway invented the concept and
he his first description of it was on
all numbers great and small not only big
and small but inside and everything and
so
people know what the real numbers are
and i call them surreal because there
are infinitely many serial numbers
between any two real numbers i thought
the numbers between all the other
numbers already existed so yes that's
what almost everybody thought except
conway so i learned about it i happened
to be
visiting calgary in canada at the same
day that john kahn was up there and we
had lunch together and he had recently
discovered this cut this concept which
we're going to describe during our lunch
he wrote out on a napkin
all the rules of of definition of
surreal numbers i was enchanted by this
idea of course i had lots of other stuff
to do but i kept the napkin i took it
home with me the basic idea you have a
new way to describe this all numbers you
build up all numbers starting from
nothing and actually nothing is
kind of the representation of zero
but then you can use zero to describe
another number which turns out to be one
and you can use zero and one to make two
other numbers one which is two and one
of which is a half and you can continue
creating more and more numbers it's
something like the creation of a
universe here we're creating a universe
of number but the numbers that you get
are always the denominator is always 2
or 4 or 8 or 16 or something
that you don't get ever you don't ever
get one third throughout the first part
of this process but you keep on creating
numbers until you go to infinity then a
big bang occurs and all of a sudden you
get all the real numbers the next day
after that then you create infinity plus
one and infinity minus one you also have
one over infinity which is a number
that's
bigger than zero but it's
less than any
positive real number that's why i
started calling them surreal because
there's a number like pi plus one over
infinity this is between pi and every
real number that's greater than pi and
also we keep on going and we keep on
creating so at some point we get one
half of infinity and we get square root
of infinity and we get infinity to the
infinity all these numbers that we get
we can add subtract multiply and divide
them so it goes way beyond any kind of
numbers that people ever conceived of
before these sound like tiny slivers
that we're dropping into gaps that we
didn't even know were there
we got the tiny slivers and we also have
the reciprocal of the
one over a tiny sliver which is which is
a gigantic thing larger than we've ever
people ever thought of before so that's
why conway called them all numbers great
and small one night in the middle of the
night i i said hey i bet why not i call
them serial number but the main
inspiration that i had was i said wait a
minute this is so cool i think maybe i
had to write a book for high school
students that would teach them what
surreal numbers are there was a need for
a book that shows how mathematical
research is done and and how you take
some simple
laws and
and create gigantic uh
universes out of simple laws and the
process of discovering is
is uh something that's usually not
taught in schools you you just are
taught the facts but but you don't get
to see the thrill of
developing these facts i woke my wife up
and we were it we were it turned out we
were on sabbatical here in in norway and
and i s and uh well maybe i didn't wake
her up until the morning but anyway i
had the idea in the middle of night and
i couldn't go to sleep
i said wait a minute a book like this
ought to be written i was already years
behind on on books that i promised to
write
and i'm still not done writing that was
50 years ago but i told my wife you know
jill i decided i have to write another
book
but it's only going to take me a week
she said well you know that's actually
kind of a nice idea
time in your life when you can do this
here we are in sabbatical and so we
worked it out that uh
that a few weeks later i i would rent my
hotel room in downtown oslo and spend a
week writing writing this book she would
come visit me
a couple times a week
because we always wondered what it would
be like to have an affair in a hotel
room so
that was the plan and it actually worked
out so marvelously it was probably the
greatest week in my life i started out
every morning having a big norwegian
breakfast
my hotel was very near where ibsen used
to live so i could get some of his vibes
at breakfast there were a group of 50
american students and i could listen to
what they were saying because i had
decided to write this book
in dialogue between between two
characters
alice and bill might as well show you
the book because here's the book and you
can see alice and bill here my wife did
illustrations how 2x students turned on
to pure mathematics and found total
happiness if you look on the web you
find out that there's a bimodal
distribution of reader comments there
are those who are looking for
beautiful mathematics and those people
are rating it at five
and then there are people who are
looking for a novel and and some cool
sex scenes and things like this and
they're rating it to zero and they're
saying it's the stupidest thing i ever
did and why would i why would anybody
waste his time so it's a kind of a
litmus test as to as to what you like oh
by the way uh a is alice and b is bill
but there's one line here which is which
is said by conway
and i went and visited john conway a few
months later to
to make sure that i could uh i could
quote him so in this particular part
he's kindly says rubbish wait until you
get to infinite sets alice says what was
that did you hear something i sounded
like thunder bill says i'm afraid we'll
be getting to the monsoon season pretty
soon so isn't that the only line for
commonwealth
i believe it's the only line that conway
has in here in the book he's he's the
creator
and he's not only j.h conway but he's j
h w h
which is an allusion to the
tetragrammaton the hebrew name for god
and the
characters in the book discover two
axioms on a stone tablet and also some
markings on the stone tablet a surreal
number consists of two parts and and you
indicate it by brackets and a colon you
have a bracket and on the left left of
the colon you
you put some
number and on the right uh some set of
numbers on the right you put some set of
numbers and then you create more numbers
so so you start out with this
with this number which is zero and then
if you put zero on the left you get a
number which co which is called one and
if you put zero on the right you get a
number which is called minus one and
this stone that alice and bill find
has these markings on it but they have
to they have to decode what it means for
these markings to do even though i have
hardly any plot in in this book the fact
that as i do
refer to nature and have a little story
going on meant that i i was watching
everything in the world much more
intensely not only was i listening to
what these students said at breakfast
but i'm also
seeing the
the colors
the leaves on the trees the everything
outside there was more too because every
morning i was actually trying to create
the theory myself conway had told me the
thing and i and i saved the napkin on
which he wrote
he wrote it down but i lost it somehow
in the next in the next month
so i had to uh i had to try to remember
it and then i had to try to remember how
did he prove all these marvelous things
that he had told me about during the
learn and i purposely didn't plan that
in advance but every day i i would work
on it and then
the mistakes that i would make i the
characters in my story would make those
mistakes and and but but then eventually
i you know i i i got further and further
and
and i was able to develop the theory had
conway not published to himself
no no he had a he had this report all
numbers great and small was his report
and then he was writing this book on
numbers and games which came out a few
years late but
at that point it was brand new if you
got so much pleasure from this form of
writing why don't you do it more often
oh no it's too it it's too scary
it's not sustainable i
i think
these are moments that
that
are come once in a lifetime but but i
think also there was
it was it wasn't just me there was
something the ideas were coming to me as
if they were being dictated
by some muse the last thing at night i
turn out the light the next several
sentences would flow into my head i
couldn't sleep so i turn on the light i
would write down those sentences but i
did they were coming so fast i only had
time to write the first letter of every
word and
so i jotted that down turn out to like
go to sleep the next morning i can
figure out
what i was going to say and continue but
if i have been doing that all my life i
think i'd be dead long ago too so the
characters discover this rock and it's
covered with
with with hebrew writing uh that just
explains two rules and everything flows
from two rules the first rule is every
number corresponds to two sets of
previously created
numbers and furthermore
there's a left set in the right set
nothing on the left is greater than or
equal to anything on the right that's
the first rule this makes a new number
the second rule describes what does it
mean to be
greater than or equal so this is the
number that we call zero there's nothing
on the left and nothing on the right
here
we put zero on the left and nothing on
the right
and this is a number that we now call
one but on this stone that alice and
bill discovered
it was indicated by
a vertical line
and and if we put zero on the right and
and nothing on the left then we get
something on the stone was indicated by
horizontal line now
this
sort of day zero is when when we got the
number zero
the next day we got the number one we'll
call it day one
on day two
uh
now we can have a set of numbers
so so we can put
zero and one on the left and nothing on
the right for example and this is
actually
turned out to be two
and
or or we could put
zero on the left and one on the right
this is the number that turns out is
going to be one half
but now there was there was a classical
definition of real numbers
but by dedication called dedication cuts
you have a set of rational numbers on
the left instead of rational numbers on
the right that defines a cut between the
two and that gives real numbers so so
it's
conway's genius was that keep on going
and allowing besides rational numbers to
allow any set of
serial numbers after i get to a point
where i have zero
uh and
and one let me put a comma here and one
and two let's call it and and you get
all of these here
but nothing on the right this is
infinity then we find out what was
infinity plus one and
and that turns out actually you got an
infinity here
these rules might have been invented
before dedication and that everybody for
100 years had learned about this in
school and we considered that this is
the way
numbers are then physicists would have
said that this is actually part of the
real universe that these numbers aren't
strange but that that these are basic
and and people probably would have
discovered the real numbers as a
as a special subset of the serial
numbers there's no reason for us to
think that the universe obeys the the
laws of real number people used to think
that
that the real world had euclidean
geometry but now people know that
base bends the patterns that are
revealed here are as mind-boggling as
anything in mathematics and are far from
being explored every year more and more
converts
come along and we find people winning
prizes because they've advanced the
theory of serial
number is which is a subtle point so you
know i i lost the napkin but the uh it
turned out that
the rule that i gave in my first draft
during those six days was not
his rule actually but it was it was
certainly different here for example his
chinese translation
don't like thinking of my impending
death um
and
you know i haven't got all that many
years left i don't quite know how many